[Música]
las décadas de espera hanwari Ibrahim de
75 años es ahora el Primer Ministro de
Malasia su ascenso al poder ha sido una
saga de revés y puñaladas por la espalda
de Padre diputado y madre política nació
en la política de 1947 pronto fue el
chico de oro del Primer Ministro Manatí
muhammad de la organización Nacional de
malayos Unidos y a los 30 años ocupó
cargos ministeriales como el de ministro
de finanzas y el de vicep Primer
Ministro de 1993 Aunque era un Dúo
famoso para su dinamismo empezaron a
aparecer grietas entre agua y magazine
cuando se enfrentaron a la crisis
financiera asiática de 1997
anuar fue destituido de sus cargos y
expulsado del partido en 1998 acusado de
corrupción y posteriormente de sodomía
acusaciones que según él tenían una
motivación política condenado a nueve
años entre rejas El veredicto
desencadenó protestas fue tratado con
violencia como preso y una foto de su
ojo morado infligido por el entonces
jefe de policía llegó a los periódicos
de todo el mundo el tribunal supremo
anuló su condena en 2004 y fue liberado
tras un breve paréntesis su regreso en
2013 fue breve Ya que en 2015 volvió a
ser encarcelado por sodomía siendo
indultado por el Rey en 2018 las
elecciones de ese mismo año hicieron que
se formarán extrañas alianzas unir
fuerzas con el mismo Manatí que le había
despedido a finales de los 90 el acuerdo
consistía en que harían caer a su
antiguo partido entonces sumido en el
escándalo financiero de mil millones de
dólares que aunque más sería
inicialmente Primer Ministro y
entregaría el cargo más tarde el acuerdo
no se mantuvo y la alianza se derrumbó
en menos de años al hacerse cargo de un
país dividido y con una economía han
desaceleración anuar promete reformas y
el fin de la corrupción